getting in shape for a superhero movie
is practically half the battle
so it's exhilarating to watch an actor
rise to the occasion of getting ripped
for his or her role from Scarlett
Johansson's acrobatics is Black Widow to
Chris Hemsworth's otherworldly biceps
the cast s to almost become otherworldly
themselves before they can appear on
screen for the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and with Avengers infinity war arriving
as easily the biggest most bombastic
Marvel film yet there's no doubt the
massive cast had to really crank it into
overdrive to get fit for the big battle
here's how our heroes shaped up to
showdown with Thanos in infinity war
heavy lifting Sebastian Stan's
friendship with his personal trainer Don
Saladino is pretty well documented
they're all over each other's Instagram
feeds and Saladino was a key player in
getting Stan shredded for his role as
the Winter Soldier Stan's stuck with
Saladin awhile prepping for the third
Avengers outing and revealed that the
key to their training method is to keep
it heavy most bodybuilding workouts tend
to involve lifting lighter weights at
higher rates of repetition instead Stan
and Saladino kicked every day off with
big bulky lifts there are videos online
of their workouts with plenty of body
building style lifts you know you get up
in the morning it's not you know even on
the weekend if it is getting there for
an hour you know get through it push
yourself through it you're tired and do
something it clearly got the job done as
Stan is looking killer as the Winter
Soldier not bad for the end of the world
eating right exercise is obviously very
important to getting an actor in shape
to play a superhero but dieting can be
just as crucial for her return as the
Scarlet Witch elizabeth Olsen kept
nutrition in mind
Olsen's nutritionists Philip go glia has
openly discussed Olsen's goals for
Scarlet Witch in the new film and says
she focused heavily on body composition
this meant her diet was radically
restructured and she eliminated gluten
dairy and yeast altogether and ate seven
to eight meals per day largely
consisting of fruits vegetables and
chicken and fish as proteins it honestly
sounds like a nice guy
right up until you remember it means
saying no to pizza mixing it up Chris
Evans has been hitting the gym for
nearly 10 years now to get in shape to
play the star-spangled Avenger Captain
America so to keep his routine from
getting stale at
has incorporated quite a bit of variety
into his routine evans doesn't play up
any singular exercise over others and
instead hops around from body weight
movements like pull ups to weighted ones
like classic bicep curls and kettle
weights the most surprising thing about
all of his workouts is just how
approachable they are sure they're going
to be a little intense for anyone who's
never done them but Evans workout can
probably be done on your own at your
local gym the buddy system Scarlett
Johansson has been playing Black Widow
for nearly 10 years now and those
constant workouts can get to be awfully
monotonous so Johansson solution is to
go to the gym with a friend in this case
co-star Sebastian Stan while it doesn't
seem to have been an everyday thing
Johansson tagged along for some workouts
with Stan and his trainer in
preparations for the shoot who doesn't
love the mental image of Black Widow
yelling at a sweaty exhausted Bucky to
squeeze out one more rep making arm day
to become the god of thunder Chris
Hemsworth has to get pretty huge all
over but there's one area he seems to
pay special attention to Thor's hammer
swinging arms need to be huge and since
his getup tends to be sleeveless his
trainer maxes out the days they work
those muscles Hemsworth is already a
pretty big dude but he's by no means
Thor sized at all times it makes the
work he puts into getting big enough to
play the god of thunder all the more
impressive
nothing fight training even the most
artistic superhero films feature a few
central scuffles so it's not just about
looking tough the actors also have to
convince audiences that their sparring
techniques are legitimate during action
scenes and since his character is
arguably one of the most hand-to-hand
fighters of the bunch Tom Holland
doubled down and got into the ring at a
boxing gym colin has been boxing for
some time now but incorporating boxing
into his workouts prepping for infinity
war ensured that the muscle he put on
for his newest outing as spider-man
wouldn't just be cosmetic Colin can
throw a punch for real which lends a
cool air of legitimacy to any moments in
which Spidey's fists get to work odd
inspiration Dave Bautista has now gotten
in Drax the destroyer shape for two
Marvel films and he managed to avoid
flex helling for infinity war by taking
inspiration from a co-stars progress
Lancel wash Carla josh brolin didn't
have to get ripped to play Thanos thanks
to the magic of visual effects but
Thanos isn't the only comic character
he's playing this year he'll also be
appearing in Deadpool 2 as cable and he
definitely got jacked for that role
Brolin is on the older side for a
superhero actor and Batista took a good
bit of inspiration from seeing his
co-star get buff for his turn as cable
he publicly talked about how it inspired
him to train even harder to prep for his
role as Drax getting the character
pumped up to maximum levels of
destructive capabilities keeping secrets
although many of his co-stars are happy
to open the books on their fitness
regimens for the MCU chadwick boseman
likes to keep a few his cards close to
the chest Black Panther and infinity war
were shot around the same time so
Bozeman's fitness routine doubled as
preparation for both appearances while
he later opened up a bit more bozeman
actually kept pretty mum when asked how
he was getting in shape for the film
saying a lot of strength and flexibility
but I'm not gonna say anymore how do you
know it's not kicking right now I might
be covering something up in other words
Bozeman was suggesting that he was
already in superhero shape long before
he signed up to play pachala
that's about as much modesty as you
might expect from the king of Wakanda
learning the blade sometimes
weightlifting and cardio alone won't cut
it when it comes to preparing for the
physicality of a role for black panther
star Danai gurira weapons training was
just as key as anything to ready her for
the role guerreras history of sword
combat training for her part as the
katana wielding Michonne on TVs The
Walking Dead came in handy for the
actress her MCU character OCO yay
the leader of the Dora milosh I might
not use a katana herself but Guerrero
found the combat training from as shown
helped tremendously her ability to swing
a spear was completely convincing in
Black Panther and considering she and
her army will have their hands full in
Avengers infinity war we're in for a
pretty awesome fight when the new film
drops
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Applause]